let's talk about how serious things are
getting this is interesting we have a
story from fox news jonathan turley says
fbi's involvement in alleged theft of
ashley biden's diary raises legitimate
concern the fbi raided the home of
project veritas founder james o'keefe
over a stolen diary belonging to
president biden's daughter the new york
post editorial board i think said this
is beginning to look like a political
prosecution of an opposition journalist
so for those that don't know the story
project veritas apparently
at some point came into con contact with
ashley biden is joe biden's daughter i
believe correct yes yeah which i didn't
even know he had a daughter until like a
week right yeah so uh
some some veritas journalists
came into possession i believe they did
of the diary and they said we couldn't
corroborate so we tried turning it over
the fbi raided james o'keefe's house i
believe it was his house as well as
several of his uh to get the diary of
reporters i don't know why
like what what their claim is they had a
search warrant did they did he did they
get the diary i'm asking because i
wasn't uh tracking this i don't know for
sure what their grounds for searching
for it may have been it was it was part
of a federal investigation into the
stolen diary of ashley biden the new
york times reported the raid took place
early sunday saturday morning just days
after the homes of two project vertos
associates were also the subject of
search warrants
why would the fbi be coming in on this
turley asked on america reports project
veritas said it didn't run the
information and notified local
enforcement so there was a legitimate
concern when the fbi becomes involved in
this type of story as to whether it is
going outside of those navigational
beacons that we use to judge whether
they are acting independently so i don't
know if they were looking for the diary
perhaps they were a lot of people are
saying this proves the diary is now true
it's legitimately the diary in which
case there's a lot of really messed up
stuff in there so that i was just gonna
say can i play devil's advocate real
quick yeah they might maybe i doubt it
but maybe if the fbi was doing righteous
investigations in this case needed
information that's only found in the
diary that can corroborate some pretty
nasty stuff that they're because we know
there's an open investigation against
hunter biden it's still open in delaware
it hasn't been used
no for sure i'm pretty sure it's against
joe biden like it's actually talking
about her dad and like messed up stuff
yeah a little messed up yeah messed up
stuff i don't i don't i don't know i
mean i'd like to believe the fbi
heard about the diary and said we need
to get this because it proves joe biden
did something wrong but it actually just
sounds like the fbi is like quick
protect the president go after
journalists and that's that's exactly
what it looks like unfortunately so
so this is crazy look it isn't the fbi
going after the russiagate hoaxers well
john duramus i wouldn't say the fbi is i
definitely wouldn't say chris ray and
this fbi are doing anything to help
correct the wrongs that were implemented
under james comey but i would say john
duramus by indicting these people and
making this information public which is
very different um so it's special it's
special counsel it's like 15
investigators that are huddled they're
cordoned off from the rest of the fbi
they don't report to anyone but john
durham john durham reports to no one but
the attorney general um it's a pretty
close-knit circle and uh so keep going
we can combine a few of the segments we
did earlier today we have the fbi going
after project veritas we have the fbi
having evidence in in the kenosha
incident
and not releasing it apparently they
lost it as aerial footage they lost it
yeah they apparently and then they
recovered it recently
then we've got apparently there's
reports about uh when it comes to
january 6th the fbi i could factor me on
this one guys they provided information
to hbo but not to the defense or the
defendants so the fbi had information
relating to it that wasn't released
it really sounds like the fbi as a whole
is like rogue
operating totally politically
and targeting anyone who opposes
the establishment party the democrats
for the most part and the neocon allies
and that's and that's that's a hard
argument to rebut and i'll only say this
that a lot of the guys i work with are
still there they're not running it every
case you mentioned is one of the highest
profile cases the fbi is handling right
now so it goes to the director's
doorstep right nothing happens in any of
those cases without the director of the
fbi knowing and i do still think that at
the top of the fbi there are people that
don't want the american public to see
what actually happened they don't want
them to see evidence of innocence like
in the written house case where they're
talking about the jan six incidents is
there's there's what um like ten
thousand hours of footage they haven't
turned over to jan six defenders are
these people just pull it like they're
in the cult they they they're true
believers of the the propaganda or they
the puppet master is pushing the lies
here's what i say i say this about
millie and dod and we can talk about all
that and all but
99 of the people who sign up to serve
sign up to serve the mission the very
few at the top that have been corrupted
like the james comeys and the chris rays
and the rod rosensteins and the like
they think the mission exists to serve
them and that's how i put it to people
and that's the only way i've been to
successfully explain it to think that
the fbi is doing the right thing here to
go after wrongdoing inside the biden
administration is very optimistic
that's why i said i was playing
again
they did hold on to that hunter biotin
laptop for a while yeah and there's so
many incidences of the fbi looking the
other way uh i mean there was there's
documents stolen from trump and the fbi
never intervened but they're intervening
on this particular case that could make
the president look bad really shows you
that
you know the agency is definitely
becoming more and more political because
when you when you read the headlines i i
remember when i read the headline it
sets the chilling effect it's it's meant
to scare you it's meant to uh put fear
in people and actual journalists who are
going out there putting their necks on
the line saying that hey i'm gonna have
the fbi break down my door if i try to
break a story
a legitimate story i think the case of
julian assange also tells that story
very uh perfectly amanda that released
documents tried to do what the
mainstream media used to do
and uh is still in jail for it i mean
that's a crazy story that i believe uh
has a long time coming from for for some
actual justice that hasn't been there
yeah julian assange a whole mother
did you have anything to do with julian
assange not personally no um i didn't
work on those on those cases i probably
saw the documents but i didn't work on
them it's it's a good example of where a
lot of us a lot of people who are not
you know republicans not traditional
conservatives thought trump missed a
huge opportunity there was ross ulbricht
there was also julian assange people he
could have pardoned and instead he's
like he would be part of like the former
mayor of detroit who was like crooked or
something some rapper
people at the you know at the end of the
administration and i stayed through the
whole through the end and people and i
had no i was the chief of staff at dod
running dod at the end trying to figure
out afghanistan and everything else
people could be calling me they'd be
like hey can you get me a pr you know i
know so and so can i get a presidential
party and i'm like what
what do you want me to do like i'm in
the you know the military like i'm like
and also pardons
you know they have some use but it's a
really dirty business every
administration always part clinton obama
they're pardoning terrorists they're
pardoning cronies why andrew cummo he
pardoned a whole bunch of really nasty
people
before he went out of office yeah yeah
and and i think that's no favors i guess
saw somebody game and kickback they just
continue to politicize the the apparatus
that's supposed to serve the people it's
money man well yeah
look you're on your way out of an
executive office and someone's like hey
in three years i can write you a check
for 100 grand you're like pardoned boom
or remember when i wrote you that check
for 50 million back then you know
i funded your super pac to the tune of
50 million ah who do you want to pardon
who would fill it out to this person
that's why i wanted nothing to do with
that business this is crazy about
project veritas though um
i'm
i'm
i don't i want to be careful how i say
this but james o'keefe is very brave
because he's got the most powerful
people in the world mad at him yeah i
know what that's like
yeah
isn't it weird though i mean you're in
the trump administration you were in a
powerful position and you were still
being
like assailed essentially
nonstop
when i went over to dod i mean adam
schiff hasn't given up but he never will
but that's fine um i know every time he
attacks me i'm doing the right thing so
you know he decided to give me his
vendetta subpoena for jan six it's gonna
cost me a fortune but i know i'm doing
the right thing i gotta do it as evil i
got nothing to hide but well so so how
do so i don't i don't want you to give
away too many details on things you
can't talk about but how does it end up
costing you money if they subpoena you
lawyers i gotta go hire lawyers a team
of lawyers to go in there and walk me
through the entire process of reviewing
documents preparing for testimony flying
them in then having them there got to
get clearances turned back on i just
have a security clearance oh wow all
these logistics you know you start
turning the till i don't save five seven
hundred dollars an hour
so what would happen if you didn't get
any lawyers well i mean that would be
dumb because then i'd be going over
there unprepared not ready to testify
into
not a courtroom but a venue full of adam
schiff and his cronies and that would
just go poorly and that's what they do
they hit you with these so they take you
off mission like for me fight with cash
and everything else i'm trying to do um
and then they're like well it's going to
cost them a fortune so here you go and
here's the kicker right
no one called me and said hey cash do
you want to come and testify will you
testify have you written a letter asked
me to do it
i've got nothing to hide i'll always
tell the truth about jan 6 but they
didn't do it on purpose so i don't know
if you can comment on this but is this
why steve bannon is like saying screw
off
uh i think steve's steve's got a little
different different uh approach to this
um and i think he's doing it because he
just doesn't care
um and he doesn't respect the authority
of the committee now whether or not i
have respect for any of the members on
the committee putting that aside i still
have respect for the institution of
congress where i used to work and i
would like to actually honor that but
these people are
the definition of evil yeah and when
you're if you're somebody who actually
reads the news and you're an honest
person regardless of your politics you
can recognize
adam schiff as an evil evil man
i don't i don't i i don't like saying
you know evil because i don't like using
that word lightly but i mean this
genuinely when when you know what did he
do you mentioned earlier he held up an
envelope claiming in the envelope as
evidence of russiagate making it up yeah
we learned in these private uh hearings
he was like we've heard all the evidence
and then the transcripts come out and
it's like never happened he's just
straight up lying to people and they and
they believe records the phone right he
released phone records of an american
journalist and you and me
look it was john solomon
he's an american gentile right american
journalist yeah adam schiff released his
private information mine too and yours
can i tell you what happened after stuff
like that the jan6 subpoena and
everything like that i got death threats
i got multiple death threats i got
called the nastiest things i've ever
been called in my life and they asked to
cut my head off repeatedly not ask they
said we're going to come take out your
head off now i don't care i can take it
but my family's got to read that right
it's in you know it gets out it's in the
media but these people on capitol hill
they don't care they don't care and
these people being led by the number one
problem in congress which is adam schiff
this is
it's it's it's it's a crazy world when
you know what's really going on when you
look at the lawyer i can't remember his
name who tweeted out as soon as trump
got elected we're going to impeach him
then he ends up being one of the
impeachment lawyers
they're clearly colluding and planning
this from day one because they are
psychopathic authoritarians who don't
care about how democratic constitutional
republics are supposed to work well they
do if it works for them but not not if
not if they lose thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you